Joe Biden feeling the heat over the
Ukraine scandal the controversy now
threatening to derail his presidential
campaign here's why if Democrats plow
ahead on impeachment Joe and his son
hunter could be forced to testify in an
official Senate trial and now Lindsey
Graham is offering Rudy Giuliani the
chance to testify before his committee
about potential Biden wrongdoing and
that's just the beginning of sleepy
Jewish troubles he's got another huge
problem
big money Democrat donors who are
reportedly frustrated over his many
gaffes disastrous debate performances
and how he's handling Trump's attacks so
far Abidin his main response to the
Ukraine controversy is rage here's what
I know
I know Trump deserves to be investigated
you should be asking him the question
why is he on the phone with a foreign
leader you should be looking at Trump
Trump's doing this because knows I'll
beat him like a drum it's not a conflict
of interest there's been no indication
of any conflict of interest what he's
doing that no president has ever done
and just breaking the White House
sending a letter to House Democrats
demanding they drop impeachment the
letter calling the inquiry
constitutionally invalid unfair and an
attempt to overturn the 2016 election
and influence 2020 and says they will
not comply with this impeachment inquiry
all right so the New York Times over the
weekend and I came out with this big
story about how Biden's reaction was a
case study in political indecision and
he just struggled to meet the moment he
waited a week or two to do anything and
at the end he just yelled at a reporter
and put out an op-ed I mean an op-ed
where's he been and and the Biden
campaign said you too New York Times I
cannot even believe you're doing this to
me
but that quotes in a in the article that
I thought were the most troubling if I
was a combined imperson are the ones
that are not amiss from the donors now
donors don't always have the best feel
for what needs to happen on a campaign
they will always call you up and say you
need to be doing something different
than you are but you don't see this kind
of thing for
Warren mayor Pete even Harris or Booker
who has not been able to raise a lot of
money clover Charlie you don't actually
see blind quotes in a paper basically
saying they're screwing this up and I
think that's often because you have
donors who have friendships with people
in the media and they want to be the one
they want to be called upon in the
future so they are they're basically
trying to show their cards but they're
about to turn then they're gonna pivot
away from him and that's what I would be
worried about if I were the Biden's and
some of them have been pivoting away
because he did not have the fund raising
he expected remember when Biden said you
know he wants to meet Donald Trump
outside the gym and he's gonna knock him
out well Donald's been waiting outside
the gym and where's Joe been well III
said this last week or maybe was a week
before I can't remember
Biden's cozy swampy nepotism resonates
far more clearly than Trump's inquiries
about it
right this is a conflict of interest
based on favors for his incompetent son
if Biden is beholden to China to Ukraine
shouldn't the media welcome this inquiry
after all they spent three years talking
about collusion and obstruction
shouldn't they want to revisit this
relationships if it had an impact on an
election of course in between your
writing of books about Russian collusion
maybe you could look into this I know
you're still working on your on your
advance getting your advance for your
book on Russia but you could actually do
this but this new Biden reminds me of
I'm playing up because you told the nice
story yesterday about buying uh throwing
stars so when I was living in London I
was invited to play soccer among a group
of high school kids and I decided to
play because I had played soccer before
and I felt like yeah I could handle this
and I'm in my head on the sidelines I'm
watching them play and I'm going you
know I could pass and score among these
guys I might even impress him you know
the moment I set foot on the field I was
like a tackling dummy they just went
around me I look like a tackling dummy
and sunglasses I was completely out of
my league that is Biden now when he was
on the sidelines he saw that he could
compete and he could play now he's in
the game and he can't keep up and it's
noticeable I can feel like when you're
walking around and you want to tighten
every bolt with an Allen wrench because
he's just all shaky and stuff and I
think that it's I think
he's gonna be out in a few months yeah
he's definitely on the decline Juan this
letter that just came out calling the
whole thing constitutionally
illegitimate saying it's rigged against
the president and Republicans Adam
Schiff who's leading it is tainted he
can't be trusted and basically throwing
down the gauntlet says put up or shut up
to the Democrats I think you could throw
that letter in the trash I mean I guess
that's in the president's great and
unmatched wisdom as he advertised very
stable genius and now he has his lawyers
putting out letters I don't know I guess
it's really you know it's it's
supposedly addressed to the Democrats I
think it's really intended for
Republicans but I think the Biden story
just let me comment on that before I
come back to that letter Jesse I think
that it's very interesting that in polls
that are out today
but the first time you see Elizabeth
Warren as the number one Democrat in the
poses the Quinnipiac poll has her at 29
Joe Biden at 26 and now in the Real
Clear Politics average she's you know
it's clearly within the margin of error
I think it's 0.2% ahead of Joe Biden to
me that's much more interesting let me
just go a little bit further on that her
gain is not coming out of Joe Biden her
gain is coming out of people like Kamala
Harris Pete Budi Jake they are going
down down we are now down to a three-way
race which is Biden Warren and Bernie
Sanders who recently was ill with the
heart attack we'll see how he does if he
can get the energy up at the upcoming
debate but to me this is shaping up as a
three-way race now if we go back to this
letter
it seems to me Biden may not be doing so
great and by the way all these donors
they're nervous and at least all the
time they're always nervous and they
want Biden to be more combative from
your perspective they wanted him to
really go after Trump in a vicious way
and Biden is just not that guy right
well you'd think if someone Jedidiah was
going after your integrity when he was
going after your family you might come
out of hibernation and throw a few
punches but instead he's just waited for
the media to defend him well the thing
is he he is combative like pointing his
finger and reporters faces he's
combative in the wrong way he looks like
a guy who's already lost he's very
defensive
he's on defense all the time he's
worried about his son's business
dealings he's worried about Elizabeth
Loren and the problem
that all of the worry shows in every
interaction he has when he gets on a
debate stage he doesn't look confidence
he doesn't look like he's in control
many people cannot even sight what Joe
Biden would actually do as president
he's so in unable to really prioritize
what his stand on the issues is because
he's so worried about all these things
once I saw that op-ed in the Washington
Post come out I said to myself this guy
doesn't even know how to create a
populist grassroots movement he is so he
is back in a political time when you
would hand over talking points to the
Washington Post and try to sell yourself
that way and that would be successful
that's not how it goes anymore now
you're going against the likes of
Warren's and Sanders who have that
populist energy who know that of tubbses
gotta tap into a crowd and he's lost and
and now you have donors come out and
looking at him and saying this guy's not
able to defend this issue with Ukraine
and he's not able to defend his own
record he's not able to defend himself
on a stage where where is he gonna shine
in the end that's gonna enable us to
feel confident to hand over our Barak
Obama
where's Obama been I mean there have
been exact use Asians that Barack
Obama's vice president is involved with
some very very sketchy stuff overseas
right under his nose and he hasn't said
one word I'm just wondering if he's
going to can I mention about the New
York so the New Yorker writes this piece
in July it was very long it's about 100
Biden and all of these allegations are
laid out in the article and under Biden
does an interview and he tries to defend
himself there and what's interesting to
me is that were in the middle of the
presidential election this big huge
feature piece shows up in The New Yorker
and no one brought it up the only time
that it got attention was when President
Trump brought it up appropriately or
inappropriately on the call and whatever
that is the only time that the media
then started to actually take action
about it but it surprises me is that the
Biden campaign didn't have something
ready knowing that that New Yorker piece
was coming out because the failure of
Democrats to know how to deal with this
kind of onslaught that comes from the
conspiracy theory crowd on the road they
should actually look at themselves
because they've been doing it for three
years this is the beautiful irony of all
of this I feel bad for Joe but I really
don't because they made their bed the
media and the Democrats at
to undo an election in 2016 and now the
slow rolling orchestrated coup is coming
back and it's going to suck him in and
what you're gonna have left is Liz
Warren who used Native Americans and her
own child to fabricate devices to
portray her as a victim I'm waiting for
her to be like Steve Martin in the jerk
in which he just says I was born a poor
black child